today we're gonna look at the night
we're gonna see how that eye moves and
how we can better play the night in our
games and get the best use out of it
now the night moves he moves basically
in an L it's either a 1 2 or 2/1 and
we'll take a look at let's say in this
example let's look at all the squares
that the knight can move to for this
square it depends on how you look at he
can move 1 2 and then 1 over or he can
move 1 and then 2 over basically he's
gonna move 1 and then 2 or 2 in than one
doesn't how - doesn't matter how you
look at it keep in mind that the knight
is the only piece and chess they can hop
over pieces so even if we have pawns
everywhere
let's take a look at an example where we
have pawns completely surrounding the
knight he can still move he can still
move too
see - he can still move to b3 he can hop
over pieces and he's the only piece that
can do that which is a huge benefit to
having the night and that's why the
knife even though he can't move as much
as the bishop is still worth three
points in a chess game because of his
ability to move over pieces now as we
saw before all the different squares
that a knight can move if he's in the
middle now let's take a look at that the
knight is on let's say let's put him on
a four now let's look at all the
different moves he commits as you can
see as he gets on the rim there's the
limited number of squares he can move to
we've cut his moves down significantly
he can now move only four squares we
have b6 we have c5 c3 b2 now let's put
them in the corner here and we'll see
that we even minimize that even more so
let's say a knight in a1 now he only has
two moves he can move to b3 or he can
move to c2 so hopefully you can tell a
knight in the middle is much much better
than a knight on the side so a lot of
times especially when you develop your
Knights early on you want to make sure
you're going towards the center and in
beginning of the game you want to make a
move like f3 you don't want to make a
move like h3 this isn't very good you
don't want to put your knight on this on
the edge if you don't have to you want
to put him in the center where he has
more spaces to attack and you also want
to have center control so I was an
important theme in chess you want to
have center control now Knights are
especially good in closed games and by
close games I mean that there's a lot of
pawn structure so we're going to take a
look at an example of
if you've seen the bishop video you may
have seen where if you have bishops and
there's a lot of pawns it's really not
good but if you have Knights it is very
good let's go and take a look an example
here as you can see we're even in
material we have the same number of
pawns in the same number of minor pieces
but why it is a lot better here remember
we said that if bishops are blocked in
by their own pond they can't really move
and even though the bishop is worth
three points and a knight is worth three
points the knight here is much better we
can position our Knight to c3 and then
we can bring our Knight to d5
and this is a very active square for us
we can start hopping over pieces and
we're not restricted black on the other
hand has a bishop which is the same
material as our knight but as you can
tell he's blocked in by his own his own
pond so bishops work really well in open
games where there's not a lot of pawns
and knights work really well in close
games where pawns are blocking the
structure so in this situation you would
rather have Knights and this is one of
the benefits of having a knight in a
game is if it's a closed structure like
this where even a queen may not be able
to penetrate this but a knight since he
can hop over pieces he can some Knights
are definitely very good in the right
situation so this is how the knight
moves this is how you should look for in
a game if the knight is good or not
because again if it's an open game it's
not gonna be as valuable as a bishop but
you do want to have Center control with
your knight at all times
and you would like to have it in a close
game so hopefully this help use in your
own chess game thanks for watching